martine Gabey so heads up the world's
first state controlled cannabis club
he's officially allowed to plant 99
flowering plants for up to 45 club
members until recently that would have
been a criminal offense in uruguay
buying or selling marijuana was illegal
the new law has changed everything
it gives a peace of mind three years ago
it was common for growers to go to jail
or to face huge legal problems if they
had five or ten plants for their
personal consumption at home it's a
quality issue the drug dealer doesn't
care if it's rotten expired or
detrimental to your health
Uruguay did allow small amounts of
cannabis for personal consumption but
everything else was banned the new law
was passed in December 2013 and it was
something of a revolution now the state
regulates the production trade and sale
of cannabis everything is coordinated by
the National Drug Board this unbalanced
approach which said that by reducing
supply I can reduce demand has failed
miserably
I say unbalanced not because it's crazy
but actually it is a little crazy in our
part of the world this approach is known
as the war on drugs but it's not only
failed it's actually generated more harm
than the drugs themselves so we want to
take a new approach to the drug problem
specifically we want to break the
illicit market and one of the drug
trafficking legs but at the same time we
also want to preserve some rights those
wanting to use cannabis now have several
options either they become a member of a
club or they can grow up to six plants
of their own and soon
they'll also be able to buy up to 10
grams a week from a chemist but only if
they are registered as a user under 18
years old Uruguay has produced a
genetically modified cannabis plant
enabling them to determine where plants
have come from in this way the
government can regulate the market only
two companies are licensed to grow the
cannabis it's someone loyally say yes
only two of us so far have licenses we
have to produce two tons each the
government already knows that more
licenses will be needed and probably the
stock will soon run out I immediately
saw this as a dream opportunity if your
iguana is smart it could develop an
industry where others might follow such
as Chile Colombia Mexico in a couple of
months registered users will be able to
buy cannabis at the chemist one gram
will cost the equivalent of one Europe a
price that illegal drug dealers won't be
able to compete with and as all users
have to be registered
there'll be no point in tourists making
drug trips to Uruguay still many are
skeptical because what demand exists
there's going to be supply there's a
huge demand from tourists still the
government is convinced it's on the
right track but the authorities are not
expecting wide support from the
international community there are
international entities countries and
regions that ignore scientific evidence
and remain convinced that a world free
of drugs is the best option so they
can't understand he paused Switzerland
for instance dispenses heroin to Swiss
citizens who proved resistant to all
kinds of treatment and they look with
horror at Uruguay and other countries
who seek to regulate the market in a
different way
let the other Avenida it may be
controversial but Uruguay is experiment
certainly offers a chance to restrict
the illegal trade in cannabis
you